[Music]
on this thursday night pandemic
projections this fall the potential
surge of illnesses beyond coven we can
expect this to ebb and flow as canada
moves the needle on fighting the omicron
variant shoddy aid for ukraine's troops
it's going to be used it more likely
will be shot at so i mean this is life
depending the problematic products
traced back to canada a global news
exclusive the un's long delayed report
on how china treated uighur muslims the
backlash from both beijing and activists
and five decades since one of montreal's
worst tragedies people were falling from
the second floor the haunting memories
at the bluebird cafe fire
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us with cold and flu season just around
the corner there's a new weapon to fight
emerging variants of covid 19. health
canada has approved this country's first
bivalent vaccine it's from moderna and
what's different about this shot is it
targets two strains half of its contents
protect against the original coronavirus
while the other targets the omicron
variant now the most common sub-variants
in canada are the offspring of omicron
the shot will be delivered in 50
microgram doses the new public health
guidelines say any adult who needs a
fall booster shot should get the new
vaccine 12 million doses are on order
and officials say there will be enough
for all adults but with many kids
heading back to school this week some
without any covert restrictions there
are concerns about the risks of another
serious wave karen lieberman has our top
story tonight
after a two-year pandemic pause crowds
returned to the canadian national
exhibition toronto's iconic end of
summer fair and reminder fall is around
the corner and hopefully like we can
bring back the normal from now on i
think things are starting to settle a
bit and it's we're looking forward to
going back to normal with a newly
approved covid19 vaccine available to
canadians targeting both the original
strain of coronavirus and the omicron
variant normalcy is the hope it is the
first bivalent coven 19 vaccine to be
authorized for use in canada and a swift
rollout is planned if we are able to hit
that 80 85 90 percent of canadians up to
date in their vaccinations
we'll have a much better winter but
before then health experts are
predicting a challenging surge in
covid19 and other illnesses we look to
the southern hemisphere almost as an
imperfect gauge of what we'll see here
in canada they had a pretty impressive
influenza season down there so covets
unfortunately not going anywhere in
ontario much looser protocols around
covid19 with individuals who test
positive no longer needing to isolate
for five days we are saying stay home
until your symptoms are improving plus
24 hours an approach that has some
physicians fearing mass spread if you
just go after 48 hours you're probably
going to infect you know your classmates
at school you're going to infect your
co-workers i don't know how i feel about
it because i think we're just living
with code right now at least a week
like a work weekend
the change comes as yet another hospital
this one south of ottawa has shut down
its er through the labor day long
weekend another signal of a health care
system in crisis two years of pressures
to definitely take
its toll on our nurses
you couple that with vacant positions
with students returning to classrooms
concern is heightened this week
saskatchewan and ontario announced
boosters for children ages 5 to 11 who
had a previous shot at least four months
prior things are going to get better
probably in the spring we're going to
have a lot more population immunity
we're going to have hybrid immunity we
have people with improved boosters and
we have a flotilla of improved vaccines
coming around the corner intranasal
vaccines pan coronavirus vaccines
meaning this could be the final
challenging fall
karen lieberman global news toronto
at europe's largest nuclear power plant
a group of un inspectors completed their
long-awaited preliminary inspection of
the site now that after the group was
repeatedly being held up by attacks in
and around the zaparisia complex
it is obvious that that the plant
and the physical integrity of the plant
has been violated several times
the head of the international atomic
energy agency says experts will remain
at the facility to provide what he
called an impartial assessment of the
safety situation the trip came amid
another round of shelling in the region
both moscow and kiev again blamed one
another for the attacks saying they were
attempts to derail the visit
and this visit comes just days after
ukraine launched a counter-offensive in
the region and while ukrainian troops
advance there are growing concerns that
some of their donated equipment
doesn't meet battlefield requirements as
jeff sample explains in this global news
exclusive some canadian companies may be
to blame
police is the last this truck near the
russian border in northeastern ukraine
is making a special delivery
badly needed body armor for ukrainian
police and military volunteers capable
of stopping a russian bullet and this
protects
all the important organs yes on a recent
visit to ukraine global news met with a
team responsible for testing body armor
and helmets for the ukrainian military
much of their supply has arrived from
abroad but when they put some of those
armored plates to the test
the results were shocking the bullets
blew through some plates others were
shattered nowadays we have a lot of
imported west that are penetrated
because of
some companies make
more a lot of money and they
they don't understand what they do
global news traced some of those faulty
plates back to canada it's
heart-wrenching right the blood's on
their hands basically with with this
stuff this ukrainian canadian runs a
toronto tactical equipment shop after
russia invaded ukraine he says demand
for body armor soared and the market was
flooded with fakes
items like this one purchased near
toronto claimed to offer level 4
protection the highest available capable
of stopping an armor-piercing bullet
but when we put this plate to the test
even with a weaker bullet it failed this
bullet went right through
this bullet went right through yeah so
it's through and through so straight
through there
and out the back
another test on a second plate did not
go through but caused major damage this
canadian veteran and former police
officer says users should look for this
stamp
very important to have this information
on a plate indicating a plate is nij
certified by the american national
institute of justice
the difference is plain to see after
testing a certified nij level three
plate with an even stronger bullet this
is going to ukraine and it's going to be
on the front line it's going to be used
more likely we'll be shot at so i mean
this is life depending there are a lot
of people who are doing war profiteering
back in ukraine global news also saw
faulty tourniquets medical devices that
apply pressure to stop life-threatening
bleeds
this one made in canada using 3d
printing technology failed multiple
tests falling apart
before sufficient pressure was applied
according to dr irina rybinkana who
tests tourniquets for the ukrainian
government thinking that this could save
your life
is a false reassurance
the manufacturer told global news its
products have been used successfully for
years in gaza and it's distributing
tourniquets to ukrainian hospitals
because the need is great like if it's
not perfect but they still will have
something
i think that is a criminal statement
because what they've got in their hands
would tear
wouldn't hold
wouldn't stop the bleeding
there have been reports of ukrainians
killed after their body armor or
tourniquets failed though none of those
items has been linked to canada
the promise of life-saving equipment can
be deadly if broken
jeff semple global news
the chairman of luke oil that's russia's
largest oil company has died under
suspicious circumstances russia's task
news agency says reveal maganov fell
from the six-story window of a moscow
hospital shortly after russia invaded
ukraine the luke oil board publicly
criticized the war and called for a
ceasefire
six top russian energy industry
executives have now died under
mysterious circumstances since the war
began
russian forces are teaming up with the
militaries from china and several other
nations for a week-long military
exercise
code named vostok 2002 it involves units
from the russian chinese and indian
armed forces along with soldiers from
belarus tajikistan nicaragua and syria
russia's defense ministry says more than
50 000 troops are involved in the
maneuvers which are being carried out in
russia's far east and the sea of japan
the exercise is being seen as a sign of
the increasingly strong ties between
moscow and beijing
a long delayed united nations report is
painting a damning picture of china's
treatment of uyghur muslims and other
minority groups the document details
what it calls credible evidence of
torture sexual violence and forced
sterilization actions that may amount to
crimes against humanity but the report
stops short of calling it genocide a
term canadian and american lawmakers use
to describe the treatment of uyghurs
redmond shannon has more on the report
and why human rights groups are upset
for five years now china's so-called
vocational education and training
centers have been suspected as locations
of alleged human rights abuses
accusations that up to a million uyghur
muslims and other minorities in the
xinjiang region were kept inside facing
torture sterilization and forced labor
china has always said there are
voluntary camps to tackle extremism this
united nations report is the most high
profile investigation yet it says
china's actions may amount to crimes
against humanity and that detainees
allege various forms of sexual violence
including some instances of rape
affecting mainly women also that there
are credible indications of violations
of reproductive rights through the
coercive enforcement of family planning
beijing didn't hold back saying the
outgoing un human rights commissioner
michelle bachelet has become a thug of
the west calling the report completely
illegal and invalid citing late
interventions from china bachelet
released the document just minutes
before her four-year term ended she did
not have the guts to release the report
earlier uyghur activists like roushana
abbas are critical of how bachelet
steered clear of the word genocide a
term lawmakers in canada and the us are
using they list the child abductions for
sterilizations and everything you know
the description of genocide is there
abbas whose sister was detained four
years ago once china kicked off the un
human rights council and she is joining
calls for ottawa to follow washington on
stronger trade rules to prevent the
import of any goods from xinjiang
suspected to have been made with forced
labor i cannot help but wonder when i
see anything that's made in china
if my sister's blood and the sweat
is in that product the report recommends
china release all detainees that is
unlikely as any action from beijing
would only appear to be an admission of
guilt redmond shannon global news london
donald trump's special master bid coming
up the former u.s president's request in
the mar-a-lago investigation plus
capturing a distant world another nasa
breakthrough courtesy of the james webb
telescope
to pakistan now where months of monsoon
rain has eased but now the country's
health officials are warning of
water-borne diseases spreading in
flood-ravaged areas
right now the focus is for the
government to get clean drinking water
to hundreds of thousands of people
displaced by the disaster which has
killed almost 1200 people since mid-june
and affected 33 million
in the past 24 hours the government
reported 90 000 cases of diarrhea in the
hardest hit province skin diseases and
eye infections are also spreading in
relief camps and unicef says more than 3
million children are at heightened risk
of contracting diseases drowning and
suffering malnutrition
the u.s justice department and donald
trump's legal team faced off in court
today the former president is requesting
a special master to look at the
classified evidence seized from his
mar-a-lago home by the fbi nathu garcia
reports from washington
marking the first time they've argued in
court about the mar-a-lago search donald
trump's lawyers had few words for the
public after the judge chose to delay
the decision mr kais what do you think
how did it go how'd it go
went well in their court filing late
wednesday trump's lawyers claimed the
august 8th search was unnecessary and
legally unsupported adding the doj would
impugn leak and publicize the material
and that the notion that presidential
records would contain sensitive
information should never have been cause
for alarm
then trump's attorneys arguing in court
on wednesday keeping the classified
documents is like possessing an overdue
library book this is not a case about
the presidential records act had he
complied with the multiple requests to
turn back the documents he could claim
executive privilege under the
presidential records act but that day
has passed the judge says a ruling will
be issued later when the written order
is due for the hearing on the former
president's request for a special master
an independent third party to review the
highly sensitive material seized from
his florida mansion but state attorney
dave ehrenberg says a special master
review could put lives at risk
the real problem is the delay in the
intelligence community review of the
damage
that this all caused the damage to our
national security and to our human
assets overseas but trump's attorney so
far unable to back up his claim that he
declassified the documents in question
that omission speaks loudly because his
lawyers obviously know that the
president doesn't have the ability to
just completely declassify things
meanwhile unlike his legal team outside
the courthouse trump has been vocal on
his social media platform explicitly
supporting q anon whose followers
believe satanic cannibal pedophiles
secretly run the government and showing
pictures of top democrats saying they're
the enemies and demanding he be
reinstated as president for donald trump
any coverage is good coverage now the
investigation for serious crimes that
could see the former president
incarcerated are not just being
downplayed in public but also before a
judge nitu garcia global news washington
for the first time astronomers captured
an image of a planet outside our solar
system using the new web space telescope
the images well they're not much to look
at but what they represent is amazing
that fuzzy dot is an infrared image of a
gas giant type planet orbiting a star
about 400 light years away from earth as
the web telescope continues to get
dialed in we should get images of much
smaller planets and an even greater
detail including those that could harbor
life
fighting for fair learning ahead is
canada's education system failing its
students with disabilities
every parent wants the best for their
child but a newfoundland and labrador
couple are fighting for fair education
todd and kimberly churchill have long
been calling for their son carter who is
deaf to receive proper assistance in the
classroom so he can get the same quality
education as children with hearing as
ross lord reports the province's human
rights commission has begun looking into
the discrimination case launched against
the province's english school district
aside from living with cerebral palsy
carter churchill is deaf the condition
his parents say they were assured would
not diminish his education but they say
it did they allege the eastern school
district in the saint john's area of
newfoundland and labrador violated the
human rights act by providing
substandard education to carter he is
going to grade six next week and he's
not able to read he is not meeting the
curriculum in his grade level at their
human rights hearing testimony confirmed
carter received a student assistant in
kindergarten to translate for him in
sign language as it turned out the
assistant could not so much as spell out
her own name leaving carter isolated and
falling behind on his learning the
church he'll say in the past five years
such problems have continued they say
all they want for their son is what was
promised in 2010 canada ratified a
united nations convention promising
people with disabilities an inclusive
quality education on an equal basis with
others when carter is older
and we explain all this to him of all
the fighting we had to do for his
education
we need to be able to look him in his
eyes
and tell him we did the best we could
with many so-called schools for the deaf
closing across canada in the name of
inclusion and the pandemic compounding
educational challenges advocates say
shortcomings are arguably more acute
than ever i think a lot of these
students are
going through the education system and
just being ignored
so i think there are probably a lot more
stories like the churchill's that
we're not even aware of the churchill's
hope the human rights commission's
ruling calls out inadequate programming
spurring action that spares other
families from the financial and
emotional strain of fighting the system
for a fair education
ross lord club news
50 years after tragedy next montreal
remembers those lost to the bluebird
cafe fire
in montreal today a tragic anniversary
for one of the worst mass killings in
canadian history on september 1st 1972
after being turned away at the door
three men intentionally set fire to a
packed downtown bar
50 years later our mike armstrong spoke
with witnesses and survivors remembering
the victims of the blue bird cafe fire
i was finishing my day at work it is a
night this retired police officer has
never been able to shake 50 years ago
andre mayville turned a corner and saw
he says a ball of fire and people in the
flames people were falling from the
second floor they jumped from the window
i was not able to help them too much
the bluebird building stood on this spot
in downtown montreal on the second floor
there was a nightclub the wagon wheel
september 1st 1972 was the friday night
of a long weekend there was a band
playing and suddenly the drummer yelled
fire
to me it's like a stampede you're
literally
running for your life brent malfara was
inside the club on that night trying to
escape what he says felt like an oven
his face was burned i had third degree
it was just from the heat and i remember
the fire the guys coming saying you
should you want to go to the hospital i
go no no
you got more important people to take
care of right now
there was just everybody in a panic the
tragedy was remembered with a ceremony
just up the street from where the bar
once stood there is today a monument to
the 37 lives lost in a crime as sad as
it was senseless
the fire was set by three men who had
earlier in the night being turned away
at the door they were too drunk hoping
to put a scare into the doorman they
returned with a plastic jug and 50 cents
worth of gas they set the staircase on
fire two emergency exits in the building
had been blocked to keep people out that
also kept people in
the drummer who yelled fire was killed
the band's guitar player don bedard made
it out after an exit door was forced
open somebody got on top of somebody's
shoulder and broke the door and
thank god they did that because i'd be
dead
the three arsonists would be sentenced
to life in prison but all were released
on parole within 10 years the loss of
life led to changes in fire regulations
but for decades it was known as
montreal's forgotten tragedy
but did not feel forgotten on this day
like armstrong global news montreal
and that's global national for this
thursday night i'm faran osser on behalf
of our whole crew i want to thank you so
much for spending part of your evening
with us
tonight's your canada well look at this
photo it's harvest in golden prairie
saskatchewan until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other
good night
[Music]
you